and it is time for the press preview our
first look at the front pages
over the remainder of the hour we'll
take a look at what's making the
headlines with the consultant editor of
the daily mail andrew pearce
and associate editor of the daily mail
kevin mcguire
let's take a look at some of those front
pages which are of course
dominated by the news that boris johnson
is facing a formal investigation
into who exactly paid for the downing
street flat renovations
uh pm's fury as watchdog launches
inquiry into
cash for curtains that's the guardian's
headline the pictures that you're seeing
there
while they show the testy exchange that
took place between
mr johnson and secure starmer at today's
pmqs
the times claims that dining street is
concerned that the possible involvement
of a tory donor in funding boris johnson
flat renovation
has left a damaging paper trail at
conservative party hq
boris painted into a corner the male's
taken events
the ft choosing to lead with the same
story
similarly the eye the metro perhaps wins
the headline battle this evening
interior resign
now the telegraph though leads with
incredibly safe for two vaccinated
people
to meet freely uh though it says it is
still recommended that people stick to
the rules just a little longer
to defeat the virus as you can see we
are once again joined
by andrew pearce and kevin mcguire gents
lovely to see you this evening uh guess
where we're going to start andrew let's
let let's turn to you and
on the daily mail front page their
headline i think it's pretty decent
boris painted into a corner tell us
about the story but also i think
a word about the significance of the
assault that the daily mail is having on
boris johnson at the moment
well i mean it fair play to my colleague
simon walters who broke this story and
has persisted with it
when many times he was being shouted
down by downey street there's nothing no
interest there's nothing in this story
but he's stuck to his guns
and it is a remarkable story because it
is unprecedented for a serving prime
minister to be investigated by the
electoral commission
which has a lot of powers it has legal
powers to
uh require people to give evidence
they'll probably be able to they'll be
able to secure
um emails texts between boris johnson
uh carrie simons will be involved as
well and
potentially the tory donald brownlow
because what we still don't know is this
we know that you get thirty thousand
pounds as prime minister for the re
for for to look after the apartment the
bill soared way above that
uh he didn't have the money to pay it we
think the conservative party picked up
the bill for 58 000 pounds
that then became a loan from we think a
tory donut called lord brownlow
and boris johnson has now repaid that
money if there's a loan
it has to be declared it's very simple
crystal clear
and any mp who gets a loan has to
declare it because the public are
entitled to know
if the politician gets a loan especially
if he's prime minister by the way
um uh what is is he is the person who's
lending the money
get any getting anything back for it
it's got to be transparent
it's a remarkable story and this is
without doubt the biggest crisis
of his premiership uh and uh
he he was in i thought he did reasonably
well in the comments actually
considering
the pressure he's under but uh this is
now
uh in the hands of lawyers and forensic
investigators
and he's in a lot of trouble um kevin as
we take a look at the front page of the
guardian and those very striking photos
of
boris johnson pointing the finger
over the dispatch box that's a secure
stamp i mean do you agree with andrew's
assessment
first and foremost that boris johnson
did quite well today
no no i agree with him that it's
incredibly serious for the
for the prime minister but i thought he
was a running raving hysterical kia
storm it got
under under his skin and promised i was
all waffle and the former director of
public prosecutions was that
called qc had him in the dock and i
think any jury would have convicted
on today's uh performance but it's
you see it's got to him he might have
been ringing newspaper editors
pretending there was nothing in it and
you very foolishly i think
blamed dominic cummings so you had those
three uh
from pages last week blaming cummings
for uh
leaks and then you know you set cuttings
off that's what he did
and then cummins comes out and he says
certainly in the case
of uh who who paid for the makeover of
the
flat at 58 000 pounds come in and say
well i didn't leak it
uh i've not spoken to about it for for a
long time since i told him
it was foolish unethical probably
illegal and breached the disclosure
guidelines it was always game set
match there alone and now is going to
have
probably months of this investigation by
the electoral commission
it could be the first prime minister
ever interviewed
under under oath on a uh on an offense
like this
and there's some speculation could the
police be called in down the line maybe
that's
those papers are running ahead of
themselves but he's not going to
enjoy this and the mistakes are one
why did he have to spend so much money
on that flat
what is wrong with john lewis furniture
that you're living in
in public digs most people aspire to
john lewis uh
furniture and then two it's the cover-up
isn't it you always see the cover-up is
the most damaging bit
he's had many opportunities to come
absolutely clean
and he hasn't he's still got an
opportunity to come
absolutely clean i don't know if you'll
if you'll take it but as the
daily mail is saying and the daily mail
is beyond this all
all the time for month after month and
commend the journalism of the mail there
and because it's the mail which
supported johnson and the tories at the
last general election you can't say this
is a left-wing
plot this is about standards and probity
in public
life yeah why did he why did he just
keep on
trying to hide it the cover-up that's
what's going to be most damaging when
it's
when it's exposed because he says well
i've paid it now
but who paid it initially he's paid it
because he's been rumbled
and he's been found out he's rather like
the shoplifter who sticks a bottle of
wine up his jumper
runs out the shop is caught down the
road by the security guard and says oh
of course i'll pay for it now
that's what johnson's been doing but
it's on a much much bigger scale
andrew and to be fair to you when you
were out of vision there was a lot of
what kevin was saying there that you
were agreeing with
in the headline in the eye the prime
minister to give evidence to the
electoral watchdog seems a fairly
anodyne headline but the
the substance of it is as you were
intimating huge i have to say though
on previous occasions when people have
talked about the electoral commission it
has not been
in terms of it being a robust
organization with massive amounts of
power it's generally
people have been complaining about the
lack of teeth that the electoral
commission have
shown on previous occasions do you
honestly think the pm is worried about
this
yeah i do think he's worried um i mean i
have to say i don't like the electoral
commission at all they they showed their
true colours after the referendum by
only pursuing people on the brexit side
for alleged
breaches of spending limits and in one's
particular case they find a young man
twenty thousand pounds
the conviction was overturned and the
fine was given back to him
but um i think he is worried because
it's it's humiliating for a serving
british prime minister
to be pulled before investigators at the
electoral commission
to explain exactly step by step how
this debt redecoration was paid for and
my god what how on earth can you spend
that much on on
doing up a flat anyway 88 000 pounds but
then
look i don't know if they had a kitchen
putting did they have a kitchen pudding
that could cost 30 000. but it's not
about sofas and cushions actually
it's about the way it was paid for and
then the attempt
to try and obscure the fact the tory
party stepped in
and then the tory donor stepped in again
and now finally we learned the prime
minister's
paid it paid the money back did he get a
loan to pay the money back i don't know
this is all going to be
this will all come out in the wash so
he's going to find a lot of his private
affairs are going to become
very public 30 grand in a kitchen
andrew i'm coming around to yours for
dinner in the very very near future
on my kitchen people can spend 30 000 on
the kitchen
kevin mcguire has seen my kitchen it's
very nice but i don't think it costs
that much
just because they can doesn't
necessarily mean that they should of
course gentlemen um right we will pause
there and we'll
return to you after the break when we
will be discussing
at this particular story arlene foster
quitting
as leader of the dup we'll have much
more on that story after this
welcome back to the press preview with
andrew kevin and myself and kevin let's
um
turn our attention to the front of the
guardian and the size of the story on
the front page perhaps does not reflect
the significance of the story arlene
foster
out as leader of the dup out as northern
ireland's first minister
no i think you're right it would have
been bigger particularly in the guardian
if boris johnson wasn't involved in his
a sleaze scandal
but in some ways arlene foster is also a
victim
of boris johnson uh and brexit
she made them a stake of believing boris
johnson
when he said there would be no border
down the uh irish sea and then one's
being created
with brexit to get his uh so-called oven
ready
deal through and as a result
northern ireland is now separated from
great britain by
that internal border and the case for
irish unification
has been strengthened so she's paying a
price
in part for that uh also in the
background she's a bit more socially
liberal than some of her
dup colleagues a party that's uh
rooted in uh in the old testament uh
and is uh against uh many of them uh
against divorce against uh same-sex
relationships
uh against abortion and she's been
she's been ousted but this comes at a
really tricky time for
for northern ireland we saw a few weeks
ago with the return of a lot of
a lot of unrest and uh it'll be
interesting to see how this now plays
out and who replaces him
yeah i mean a lot of people have been
speculating today on which direction the
dup now goes in i mean surely it's only
one it's
right well i i what would be interesting
to see is do they have a leadership
contest because you know they've never
had one in their history
it's always deals done in back corridors
in smoke-filled rooms
that's how arlene foster got that job uh
and if there's there's talk of ian
pagely's son
who's in parliament could could he
become the leader uh
but uh whoever gets the job has got a
poison challenge because they've got to
sort the
northern ireland brexit protocol out
because it isn't working
uh and there is that border down the
irish sea and
prime minister promised the dup there
wouldn't be one
and there is so i don't know who'd want
the job i wouldn't
uh final story of this uh the daily
telegraph have you
you two both had a vaccine i'm i'm
presuming you you might be able to
sit well it might be safe for you guys
to meet up in health terms perhaps no
if nothing else i'd rather not meet
kevin if i don't have to
either if if i don't know i'd have to
meet him if i'd
i might i might have asked her for a
medical exemption just so
save my uh welfare and mental health
well that's an extraordinary story
because the the deputy chief medical
officer saying
if you both if people have had both
vaccines it's quite safe to meet up you
can meet them
meet them in a house in an office in a
but but he's saying but please don't so
why
they're becoming so ultra cautious they
are indeed
not something i would suggest we ever
get from youtube guys uh lovely to see
you